you know what exactly is a log and why
do we even need logs right well
logarithms their inverses of exponential
functions it's kind of like if somebody
said to you you know why do we need
square roots well say for example you
want to figure out you know how do I
solve this equation x squared equals 100
well you say well the inverse or the
opposite of squaring is to square root
and then we got x equals 10 right or
what's the inverse of multiplying and
dividing it what's the inverse of adding
subtracting so basically the reason we
need logs is because we need a way to do
the inverse or undo what exponential
functions do and you'll see how that
plays out as we go through this video so
the first thing you want to know is how
do you switch from the Log form which is
kind of unfamiliar to us right now to
the more familiar exponential form and
I'm going to show you a couple different
ways I'm going to show you my favorite
way first now because logs and
exponential functions are inverses what
we can do is we can use that to our
advantage so if we've got log base B of
x equals n what I can do is I can
exponentiate both sides ok have this
equation using the same base as long as
these bases match so that's those are
gonna cancel each other out and now we
have ax equals B to the N right so now
it's in our exponential form we're gonna
go through some examples so you can see
how this works now if it was in this
form x equals B to the N see this is the
base this is the exponent what I'm going
to do is I'm going to take the log base
B of both sides okay to keep it balanced
remember in algebra you want to do the
same thing to the left the right sides
but the log base B and the exponential
function with base B those cancel one
another out and now you can see we're
back to where we started originally so
understanding how to switch between the
two forms is really key now a lot of
teachers okay will teach their students
this and they'll say you know this is
the base okay
this number here it's like a subscript
it's a little bit below the line this B
and this is the power okay
so n is the power that's your exponent
and then the X that's your answer or
often times referred to as the argument
okay not like getting into a
fight okay just the argument that's the
answer so if you know that's the base
that's the power and that's the answer
then you can say okay there's my base
there's my power there's my answer okay
I'm going to show you this method
because I think it's a little bit more
intuitive and easy to understand so
let's go through a bunch of examples
here so let's switch this from the Log
form to the exponential form we'll do
that first so you've got log base 3 of
81 equals 4 so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to exponentiate both sides I'm
gonna raise both sides using the base 3
why because exponential functions and
logarithmic functions they're inverses
just like we talked about earlier
squaring and square rooting multiplying
dividing adding subtracting when you do
that they cancel one another out okay so
now you've got three to the fourth power
equals 81 which we know is true 3 times
3 times 3 times 3 is 81 okay how about
this one log base 2 of 1/16 well again
we're going to exponentiate using the
same base log base to exponentiate both
sides using base 2 those are inverses
they cancel so now you can see we've got
2 to the negative 4 equals 1/16 and
you've got it let's go down to this one
log base 10 so now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to exponentiate both sides
using base 10 those undo one another and
we've got 10 to the one-half power
equals the square root of 10 and
remember your fractional exponents the
denominator is the root so that's why
that's the square root of 10 this is 10
to the first power now we're gonna go
the other direction okay we're going to
switch from the exponential form to the
logarithmic form this is the base log
okay so this is base 5 so we're gonna
take the log base 5 of both sides these
are inverses they cancel so we get 3
equals log base 5 of 125 now you can
write it either way but I'm just gonna
leave that like that for right now this
one we've got 7 squared 7 is the base so
let's go ahead and do the inverse of
exponentiating with base 7 let's take
the log base 7 of both sides to keep it
balanced these are inverses they undo
one another so you can see log base 7 of
49 equals 2 and you got it
last one here for this group of problems
we're going to take the log base 8 of
both sides
those are inverses and now you've got
1/3 equals log base 8 of
- now if you want to get more
comfortable with this process just keep
switching back and forth between the two
forms what I mean by that is see how you
have log base 8 let's just exponentiate
both sides using base 8 those are
inverses now we get back what we had at
the very beginning let's say we're gonna
want to take the log base 8 again on
both sides right
those are inverses and we're back to the
logarithmic form and you can keep doing
that forever and ever you until you feel
really comfortable with switching the
forms so that's my preferred method just
because I feel like it's more intuitive
but if you don't like that method stick
with what you like some teachers will
even just use the circle technique
they'll say this base raised to this
power equals that answer but just
remember that's the base that's the
power of the exponent and then the to
the argument is the answer so the next
step in logarithms we're going to get
into let me erase this board and we'll
get right back at you okay now we're
going to talk about evaluating logs so
when they say evaluate what does that
mean it just means find the value in the
last part that we were talking about we
were switching forms between the
exponential and logarithmic forms but
now what we're doing is we're actually
solving we're actually getting an answer
and what you can do is you can do the
same thing like we were doing in the
last part just go ahead and exponentiate
both sides of the equation so the
exponential function logarithmic
function they cancel one another out as
long as the bases are the same so now
what we have is 2 to what power equals
32 well you can see that's going to be 5
now oftentimes what I recommend to
students is just put a variable here
like X for example so log base 5 of
125th equals x right so we're not as
familiar of thinking in terms of logs so
let's go ahead and exponentiate both
sides make sure that these bases are the
same their inverses they cancel each
other out 5 to what power is 125th
negative 2 because 5 squared is 25 but
the negative exponent takes the
reciprocal right this one here log base
49 of 7 again we're just going to make
it equal to a variable X we're going to
exponentiate both sides right so those
are inverses 49 to what power is 7 1/2
because remember the 1/2 power that's
like taking the square root so the
square root of 49
seven and then I just wanted to make a
note here before I get to this next one
is that when you see log base 10 of X a
lot of times they're just gonna write it
as log X they won't even write a base
here it's called a common logarithm it's
kind of a lazy man's way of just you
know writing log base 10 of X you'll see
that on your calculator log X but that's
base 10 and then log base E of X
remember E is the natural base e 2.71
right they'll write that as Ln X or
natural log of X so these are like
shorthand so if you see that if you want
you can put an e there to remind
yourself or a base 10 there again to
remind yourself what base it is so for
this one log base 3 of 1 again we're
just going to make it equal to ax let's
exponentiate both sides these are
inverses 3 to what power is 1 well
anything to the 0 power is 1 so that's
just going to be 0 so now let's get into
the graphing so how do you graph a log
okay well here's the thing we know that
exponential functions which look like
something like this this is an
exponential growth function and
logarithmic functions are inverses but
when you want to find the inverse of a
graph what you do is you reflect it over
the line y equals ax so if we do that
the logarithmic graph should look
something like this right here now the
exponential graph notice it's getting
closer and closer to the x axis whereas
the logarithmic graph is getting closer
and closer to the y axis so this is
going to be our vertical asymptote as
opposed to when we had the horizontal
asymptote let's go through some examples
so you can see what I mean
so when you have y equals log base 4 of
X you want to graph that what I would do
what I recommend is just exponentiating
both sides okay
so now what we've done is we've
rewritten it in exponential form so
we've got x equals 4 to the Y power pick
some values for Y now as opposed to X
because it's a little bit easier to take
4 to the negative 1 that's going to be
1/4 4 to the 0 is 1 4 to the first is 4
and 4 to the second power is 16 now what
we can do is we can plot those points so
we've got let's see when X is 1/4 we're
going down 1 when X is 1 we're going
right 0 and we're
right for we're going up one and if we
go way over here 16 we're gonna be up at
2 so I'm kind of going off the graph
there but our graphs going to look
something like that ok so now the next
thing your teacher might ask you is you
know what's the equation of the
asymptotes well because this is
approaching the y-axis that's actually
the line x equals 0 so that's your
vertical asymptote they might also ask
you what's the domain and the range well
remember the domain is whatever the X
values can be and in this case X is
greater than zero you don't see the
graph over here in the negative range
it's not touching the y-axis so X can't
be 0 so the domain is X is greater than
0 and then for the range we think about
what the Y values are and you can see
this is going down towards negative
infinity gradually making its way up
towards positive infinity so the range
is going to be all real numbers ok let's
do a little bit more complicated example
so this one here what do you think the
one in the three do to the graph well
the number that's grouped with the X and
it shifts the graph in the X direction
the horizontal direction but this minus
one has the opposite effect it's
actually gonna shift it right one so we
actually have a vertical asymptote here
at x equals one okay and then what do
you think the positive three does well
it shifts it up three so we can think of
this point right here that circle that I
drew as our origin as our starting point
now we're just going to focus on the
parent function
okay y equals log base two of X we're
going to exponentiate both sides okay
these are inverses so we get two to the
y equals x so I'm gonna make a table
again I'm going to plug in some easy
values for y so this is going to give us
one half one two and four and then what
I'm going to do is I'm gonna plot the
points from here not the origin because
everything's shifting right one and up
three anyways so let's just start from
here and let's see so if we go right a
half down one that'd be right there
right one okay up zero and then right -
okay let's see right - up one like that
and then right four one two three four
up two so like something like that so
basically this graph looks something
like that
all right and you can see the domain is
going to be X is greater than one and
the range is gonna be all real numbers
so it's going up and down from negative
infinity to positive infinity okay so
that's talking about the graphing the
next thing we're gonna talk about is
expanding and condensing logs so let me
erase this board and we'll do that next
okay now we're gonna talk about
expanding and condensing logs but first
we want to talk about the properties of
logs okay just like there's properties
of exponents rules of exponents for
example when you multiply and you have
the same base what do you do to the
exponents you add them right when you
divide and you have the same base what
do you do to the exponents you subtract
them what are you doing you have a power
to power you multiply so those are the
rules of exponents you learned before
but now the rules of logs it's very
similar like when you have these two
arguments multiplied together you can
write it as a sum of two logs the main
thing is you want to make sure that you
keep the base the same whatever that
base is same thing over here if you're
dividing these two arguments you can
write it as a difference of two logs
just take the log of the numerator minus
the log of the denominator and then this
one's called the power property you can
take this exponent here and you can
bring it down in front and write it as a
coefficient now all these properties
they're reversible so when you're going
from the left to the right that's called
expanding it's getting larger but if you
go from the right to the left that's
called condensing it's getting filled
more condensed right so if you see the
sum of two logs you can write it as the
log of a product or if you see the
difference of two logs and they have the
same base you can write it as the log of
a quotient okay and then there's another
format called the change of base formula
and this really comes in handy when some
calculators they don't have the ability
to change the base they only have log
base ten or a natural log which is log
base E so what you can do here is if you
have log base B of C equals log you pick
a new base let's say base a you take log
base a of C divided by log base a of B
so for example if you had log base three
of seven you could really write this as
a common log like log base 10 of seven
divided by log base 10 of 3 now it's
easier to remember because the seven is
a little bit higher that goes in the
numerator the three is a little bit
lower that goes into 9
you just pick a new base and that's it
you can also write this as natural log
of seven over natural log of three same
thing with this one log base four or
five I would just say natural log of
five over natural log of four put that
in your calculator and you got the same
thing as log base four of five but let's
get into the expanding and condensing
now so say you want to expand log of a
times C times D I didn't write the base
there so that's considered a common log
or log base ten but because these are
all multiplied together we're going to
use the product okay rule so this is
going to be log of a plus log of C plus
log of D pretty easy right here we've
got a combination of multiplying and
dividing so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to do log of a plus log of C minus
log of B so the one that I'm dividing by
we're subtracting the ones that are
multiplied together we're adding this
one here natural log this one's going to
be I'm going to do it in two steps going
to do natural log of X minus C because
we're dividing natural log of Y times E
but you can see these are multiplied
together which we can write this as
natural log of y plus natural log of Z
right but you see this whole thing is
being subtracted so we have to
distribute that negative so this whole
thing comes out two natural log of X
minus natural log of Y minus natural log
of Z the thing to take away from this
particular example is whatever's in the
denominator you're going to be
subtracting whatever is in the numerator
is going to be positive are going to be
adding okay so that's just a quick way
to figure these ones out but you can do
it in steps like this to this one we've
got some exponents here so this is
actually going to be natural log of x
squared plus natural log of Y cubed
because you can see these are multiplied
so I wrote it as a sum of two logs then
what I'm going to do is going to bring
those powers down in front as
coefficients that's the power property
okay for logs so this is going to be two
natural log of X plus three natural log
of Y that's fully expanded and then one
here this is pretty a more challenging
one let's see it's log of let's see log
of 5 plus log of
plus two log of YC I brought down that
two in front okay and then - because
we're dividing one half log of W minus
one half log of Z so I did all that in
one step now you don't have to do it in
one step like I did I just want to show
you a more challenging one but notice
everything that's in the denominator is
being subtracted the square root is the
one-half power so I brought that one
half down in front
same thing with here the Y squared I
brought that two down in front
everything that was in the numerator
that was multiplied together I wrote it
as a sum of logs and the ones are in the
denominator I subtracted okay that's the
quotient rule now we're going to go over
to the condensing so we want to condense
these into one log so we're subtracting
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
divide and don't get confused you want
to make sure the one that comes first or
to the left is in the numerator the one
you're subtracting that one goes into
the denominator so it's like natural log
of 2 divided by X this one with the
coefficients I would bring those up as
powers first and then you can put it all
together so this would be natural log of
X cubed times y to the fourth okay
adding so we multiplied okay and then
this last one we've got quite a bit
going on here so I'm going to bring up
the coefficients okay
one half is going to make that the
square root of Z so if I do this is
going to be log of X to the fourth right
over see because we're subtracting y
squared plus that's going to be times
the square root of Z so that was a
challenging one so this has been
expanding and condensing logs now we're
going to get into evaluating equations
and solving equations using logarithms
so let me erase this board and we'll get
back with that okay now we're gonna
solve equations using logarithms so just
like algebra you want to work from the
outside in you want to try to isolate
that variable same thing here we're
trying to get that X by itself so let's
go ahead and subtract 7 from both sides
so that gives us 4 times 2 to the 3x
power equals 3 again working from the
outside in let's divide both sides by 4
so now we have 2 to the 3x equals 3/4
whenever that variable is in the
exponent position okay you need to get
it down from there we need to reverse
that
exponentiation process we want to take
the log base two okay of both sides of
the equation to keep it balanced right
so the log base two and the exponential
base two those cancel so now we have
three x equals log base two or 3/4 if we
divide both sides by three that's it
you've got it now you can do that in
your calculator I did that here for us
it's a negative 0.138 approximately okay
let's go to an example number two same
thing here you're trying to work from
the outside and you're trying to get
that X by itself so let's add 8 to both
sides so that gives us 2 log base 2 of x
equals 14 let's divide both sides by 2
we're still working from the outside in
we've got log base 2 of x equals 7 we
want to get that variable by itself
what's the inverse of taking the log
base 2 exponentiating using base 2 so we
have x equals 2 to the seventh power
which is a hundred and twenty-eight okay
an example number three here we're going
to use the properties of logs to
condense these into one log remember
when you're adding what do you do to the
arguments you multiply them so that's
going to be x squared minus 2x I'm
multiplying those together equals one
and then again we're trying to work from
the outside in we're trying to get that
variable by itself so let's exponentiate
both sides so I'm raising base three so
those cancel one another out we get x
squared minus 2x equals three I'm going
to subtract three from both sides set
this equation equal to zero I'm going to
factor okay so is this all coming back
to you from earlier in math right and
then now if we set these factors to zero
we get x equals three or negative one
but the one thing you want to be careful
with with log equations because remember
the graph looks like this right well you
can't take the log of zero you can't
take the log of a negative number that's
not in the domain okay so if we look at
negative one so you'd be taking a log of
a negative one a negative number that's
extraneous that's not possible three is
okay we're not going to be taking the
log of zero or a negative value when you
simplify that argument okay so that has
to be a positive value once you simplify
so it looks like we just have one answer
x equals three and you got it so we did
quite a bit here in this video
giving you all you need to know about
logs from evaluating to solving
equations to expanding condensing
graphing I hope you like this video
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I want
to mention if you're preparing for the
AC T or the SAT check out my huge AC t--
math review video course or my huge SAT
math review video course pack with tons
of information if you like my teaching
style you'll get a lot of those courses
and I look forward to seeing in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon